okay shall we try to pull this apart of
400 4 kilometers what do you think yes
thumbs up okay so how do we the big
question of course is how do we get 400
for farmers where is this double emerged
from can someone give me that here what
line working you my dude home video hi
okay if you do 38 / man before just
before I'll get to it well I can't all
right turns 100 why why am I writing
like why am I dividing by at 9.4 in the
first place what is actually doing okay
so you're actually kind of what this is
doing is taking this guy and using JIRA
has a name the unitary method okay
dividing by nine point four turns this
into a rate not about nine point four
liters but about 1 liter okay so it
would turn into this to buy both of
those x 9.4 that gives you one leader on
the Left need to buy that through and
then you get whatever this number
happens to be on the right hand side
okay okay so we're really be sure 10.6
okay yeah you're you're doing a
difference it so you're doing this step
over here okay so what I've done is I've
converted the race but you can see I
actually don't have one leader in my car
thank goodness I have 38 litres right so
then what do I do next from this lion
just like I divide them to a surge by
nine foot 4 i'm going to multiply both
sides by 38 do you see that so that'll
make that 38 litres that'll make this 38
x 100 on 9.4 but look at that you look
at that for a second isn't that exactly
what you told me to do just arrange a
little bit differently right there's the
same division x 9.4 there's the same
multiplication by a hundred it's the
same you okay which is why I'm dick okay
all right what do we think this one
yes yeah I think that's right yes good
my sir does it sound like a reasonable
numbers my question it's my pleasure
yeah yeah yeah no maybe kilometers per
meal okay colonas per liter what this
means is if you've got one liter of fuel
in your car how many kilometers can you
go right hmm just think about this for a
second look at these numbers for a
second part of why our intuition is kind
of struggling here is because these
numbers are kind of weird and awkward
one of the great strategies you can
always use is approximate numbers and
see if something that's like at least in
the ballpark so 9.4 give me a round
number that's nice and easy to work with
that's the place that I point for 1.4 I
just can go to 10 I mean after good
night is closer I just want an
approximation so suppose it says 10
liters for 100 kilometers okay so that
means on my 100 kilometer journey right
I've used up two liters of fuel so every
kilometer how many will show rather
every leader how much does one liter of
fuel get me if it got 100 kilometers and
I'm using 10 liters there every leader
is getting the 10 kilometers does that
make sense let me draw out the gin for
you um
here are my 100 kilometers my 100 call
it from zero kilometers and I end over
here okay the first ten kilometers I use
up on the air fuel and in the next tape
owners I use up a liter of fuel and I
keep doing it once I've done all of them
that adds up to 10 liters does that make
sense so this is my mythical ten liters
for 100 kilometers so therefore what is
my kilometers per liter it's take orders
every single time does that make sense
is this about right how I can read this
what do I do yes ok so we kind of close
part of the issue is um this number i
should point out sorry this expression
is correct where did it come from
whether I get it from I'm not saying if
the answer I'm just saying is correct
very good ok so she has taken both of
the numbers here right remember how I /
thumbs x 9.4 she's divided both numbers
by a hundred okay so getting from I use
a new color nap castagna getting from
this tuna Liza's then we've divided
beside by a hundred so what I've got
here is not incorrect it's correct but
it's not the answer it's not the answer
i haven't answered the question cuz look
at what it's saying it's yeah it's
kilometers per liter not liters per
quarter so can someone suggest to me
what we're going to do is dead yeah 404
or / 38 ok now let's just think about
this right will this what we all agreed
but this answer is right thumbs up okay
so a way to get kilometers per liter is
to divide a number of kilometers by
however many liters it took you which I
point to this question was 38 okay so
this is fine i will in fact yet what was
a 10.6 3.6 please okay that's fine I
could have done it a more direct way and
I don't have question 1 okay so if i
take it out yeah okay so what you've
done is this right so this is my very
first line yeah now I remember I said
odds 100 / 9 put for whatever that
happens to be what that happens to me is
about ten point six okay so look at what
then emerges out of this line one Lena /
10.6 sorry look at the right now one
liter per for ten point six kilometers
okay do you see that right what what is
a room it's just comparing two things
that are changing comparison to each
other right so therefore if it takes me
one liter to go ten point six kilometers
I can just as easily say I can go ten
point six kilometers for every one liter
right does that make sense I'm just
comparing these two amounts like I can
say okay for arm for 25 people in a room
there are 50 eyes well if there are 50
eyes in the room hopefully okay I don't
need 25 people as well render that make
sense so if I'm comparing these two
things I can chase the Ottoman that's
fine and so that's the way that I would
do that okay um do we agree with number
three don't agree with it yeah what's he
done what's he done it goes alright Gary
trusted okay he has he's actually
written most of we've done right what
time smooth husband multiply both sides
by 4 okay so which leaves you with this
line here today said he has added 2 to
both sides why did he had to because
he's trying to get rid of that thing
right which leaves him with this line
and then he has divided by 3 why did do
that
Game of Thrones try to get rid of that
at any stuff okay just watchin ya done
hopefully